if you've been shopping in a mall or
online for clothing recently you may
have noticed a trend
an increase in fashion promising it's
more sustainable
even the printed design is plant-based
environmentally friendly that's why 79
of our garments already have sustainable
properties more Shoppers want fashion
that is less impactful on the planet and
companies are responding it's a very
very big Trend right now so there's a
huge increase in the market that will
stop labeled as sustainable while some
companies are doing the right thing many
consumers we spoke with are skeptical
they're using all the right words but I
don't see it actually being put into
practice if I'm going to buy something
that claims to be Eco am I asking the
cashier like if they know honestly no
pretty vague terms like natural organic
sustainable vegan those kinds of terms
are being used Kelly Drennen is the
founding executive director of fashion
takes action for more than 16 years her
non-profit has been working to advance
sustainability in Canadian fashion and
so what they're doing is they're
actually misleading the consumer into
thinking that those products are made
sustainably by using those kinds of
words and making the assumption that the
consumer does not know any better and
doesn't have the time to actually do the
research and so they end up buying the
product because they think they're doing
something better for the planet
she says she's seen it all including
companies greenwashing their way into
Canadian closets it's the wild west
really in terms of what claims are being
made and what companies are getting away
with is it frustrating to you sometimes
to see these wild claims being made it
is 100 frustrating because there are
some brands that legitimately are doing
great things the ones who are doing it
properly have the certifications to back
up those claims or they're being
transparent they'll allow you sort of
behind the scenes that you can actually
get in there and see if what they're
saying is legitimate and then you've got
the brands that are jumping on the
bandwagon and taking advantage of the
consumer while deceptive Marketing in
general is illegal in Canada Kelly wants
the government to step up there's some
countries where there are more laws in
place now anti-greenwashing laws
transparency laws which really protect
the consumer at the end of the day but
like in anything there's good actors and
there's bad actors
our over consumption of fast fashion
makes the industry one of the most
polluting and problematic for the planet
in Canada textiles in our landfill is
actually higher than Electronics you've
got the synthetics the polyester nylon
acrylic spandex
that's plastic so when it is in the
landfill it's never going to biodegrade
we really need to slow down our
consumption we buy too much stuff we buy
60 more clothes today than we did 20
years ago we keep our clothes for half
as long
some consumers are paying attention list
a fashion technology company analyzes
Shoppers Behavior
it found searches for sustainable
fashion in Canada Rose by 37 percent in
2020.
it means companies truly dedicated to
sustainable practices have to figure out
how to set themselves apart
this is the photo shoot for Christy
sumer's latest collection
[Music]
she's the founder and CEO of Canadian
made clothing brand encircled
[Music]
it looks great okay now we're going to
reverse it
started the company in 2012 and about
four years in wanted to set the brand
apart from others making sustainability
claims
she applied for B Corp status a private
certification that investigates social
environmental and business practices
all at her own expense
having that third party audit was really
important to showing that we are
actually doing what we're saying we're
doing and I think at that time I had
started seeing a lot more greenwashing
start to happen a few fast fashion
brands had launched you know conscious
Collections and I was starting to feel a
lot more pressure around that and I
could see that sustainability was
becoming a challenge for us to separate
ourselves from those that were
greenwashing
part of the issue with sustainability is
the complex Labyrinth of the fashion
supply chain
[Music]
the brand is growing locally in circle
designs in-house makes half of its
Fabric in Toronto
and everything is sewn within a 60
kilometer radius of its Studio
thank you
[Music]
so this is your everyday dress that
we're doing Jack's cutting your purchase
order now
wow
all these considerations come with a
higher price
a lot of people will look at sustainable
fashion and say it's more expensive to
buy this shirt and it absolutely is
because of our supply chain because of
our labor practices because of the time
it takes to design it and the scale that
we have as a brand this idea that you
buy like 20 dresses for ten dollars that
you wear once and you toss them well
it's not sustainable for us as a planet
[Music]
education is a key component of Kelly's
work thousands of companies have
enlisted her help so much variety now
since you first launched
today she's visiting wexley in Toronto
checking out its new Fabrics
the dies the Fabrics all of that gets
tested rigorously
it's a Canadian outerwear company also
with B Corp certification
one of a small number in Canadian
apparel to have the designation we don't
work with just the industry so the
people who make and sell clothes we also
work with the people who buy it wear it
care for it and eventually dispose of it
and if we're talking about changing a
system you have to work with every
single stakeholder who is a part of that
system
and that also means Brands and
non-profits are doing most of the
educating
it's really the industry's
responsibility brands should be raising
awareness within you know within their
customer base about what positive
impacts that they are having at the same
time you know governments really need to
be stepping up as well public access to
education and knowing how our products
are being made where they're being made
and what impact they have on people and
planet is something that the government
really should care more about
[Music]
Bob Kirk
director of the Canadian apparel
Federation representing a wide range of
clothing and manufacturing companies in
Canada
whose responsibility is It ultimately I
think come
playing themselves rather than just
having a tagline a simple statement
we're green what is it what does that
mean for you Bob says some companies are
now green hushing choosing not to
publicize sustainability efforts or
claims to make those kind of claims is
easy so that's why I think a lot of
people are sort of pulling back in
larger companies in particular because
they're worried about enforcement and
they realize how complicated their
supply chain is it's all over the world
multiple factors multiple suppliers
so essentially it's being called green
hushing and it is caution they're still
doing all the things that they're doing
and again we recommend to our members
and to all companies to be very guarded
in what they say to tackle green claims
overall the EU recently proposed a new
law to hold companies accountable
including in fashion the UK is also
cracking down on fashion green washing
for now Canada is not making any changes
we don't need to change our laws we just
need to find a way that works for the
competition Bureau and for industry and
ultimately for consumers but the one
thing I would say is that the
competition Bureau has been reluctant to
to take that up they have other
priorities and that's fine but I would
say it's going to be helpful so we
reached out to the competition Bureau to
see if it plans to increase enforcement
of greenwashing and fashion the bureau
declined an on-camera interview and did
not respond to questions by a production
deadline
Kelly continues her Mission fashion is
something that we all can relate to you
know we don't all drive cars or own
homes I mean we all work clothes we got
up every day and we put on clothes we
really want to see a conscious fashion
system
and at the same time we recognize that
Perfection doesn't exist in this space
if the industry does it collectively
then we can actually you know make some
changes and Advance sustainability
foreign
[Music]